So, the process that now we want to
leverage is called Tone Mapping.
Tone mapping is an attempt to be able to
take an image, and high radiance image,
like the one we talked
about the radiance map, and
converting it to a space where we
can now actually visualize it.
So what basic thing we need to do is we
want to map one set of colors to another
in a reduced space.
And we want to basically account for
being able to display it on a medium
that has a limited dynamic range.
So again even displays actually
are built the same way as sensors.
They could, they should actually
be able to go from 0 to 55.
We don't want to be able to dynamically,
and get the colors
in the space that a display can show it,
and again as a set-up printer.
And a variety of things exist
on this kind of technology.
And of course, we want to be able to
display these things on printers,
monitors, and projectors.
This is primarily to address the fact
that printers and most of the displays
right now are inadequate,
in terms of how they can represent it.
And of course, these days with 4k
displays and all that kind of stuff.
We can actually really display a lot
of high dynamic range information.
But, of course the content for
those types of displays is hard.
So Tone Mapping addresses the problem
of being able to get this contrast
reduction from the scene radiance image,
which is captured in the radiance
map to a displayable range.
It preserves the image details and color
appearance, because remember, what we
did with the HDR process was really
capture the radiance map from a scene.
But we can't display it, so what we
want to do is basically convert it
into a form and
that's what tone mapping does.
Many, many well known algorithms are
existing for this kind of an approach.
We'll be discussing some of them
in detail in this class also, and
I just list a few of them.
I encourage you to look at them.
Now before we go on,
there's one thing that I wanted to add.
If you look at this image,
I actually get bothered by both
Tone Mapping and HDR on the web a lot.
Sometimes, and
this is one of the perhaps most overused
imaging technology out there
on the internet these days and
people are actually generating images,
that to me look ghostly.
So this image of course,
is capturing all of the detail.
But with the clouds and
all of that kind of na,
natural lighting it
actually feels unnatural.
In fact this scene would have never
been naturally done like this.
So that is one of my problems with doing
over you know, use it of things like HDR
as we are actually generating a lot of
images that don't look natural anymore.
So my recommendation, use it carefully.
Hopefully, you like
the example I showed you.
Here is another example of
a similar type of an image.
I mean yes, it's a dark image.
It's a nice image.
It looks artistic, but even in the most
natural situations you would not have
seen lighting like this in a square,
a popular square, where ever you are.
So what we're really doing with tone
mapping for high dynamic range images is
taking again this whole dynamic range,
which is shown here in the real world,
and what we want to do is squish
the whole range into a 0 to 255,
and in essence,
that's what tone mapping does.
It takes the whole range and, based
on the display characteristics, and
perhaps, a few things
that I want to emphasize,
it compacts it out into this range.
So yes, you do lose information,
but if you save the radiance map,
you already have that information
that you can use later.
Things that does, it basically takes
the limited contrast information and
maps it to the medium, display medium
that you're using and preserves details.
Again, we'll be covering
a little bit more of tone mapping
online in the class.